barack obama tells americans they're
wasting time on fake outrage while the
democratic party pursues a radical
equity agenda the biden economic program
goes extreme and anthony fauci is under
fire for experimenting on puppies i'm
benchmark this is the bench bureau show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
don't let big tech track what you do
anonymize your web browsing at
expressvpn.com
ben well you may have missed the big
news last week but if you recall allison
williams was a reporter at espn she'd
already had coveted she was trying to
get pregnant and so when espn hit their
entire staff with a vaccine mandate they
said basically everybody has to be vast
or you're going to get fired allison
said well i'd rather resign than do that
and she quit to oppose the mandate right
she actually put her money where her
mouth was
when we here at daily wire saw as always
an opportunity when talented people get
let go by woke corporations for failing
to simply abide by their ridiculous
rules that's an opportunity for us we
picked up allison williams we announced
this on friday she's going to be doing a
brand new sports
special for us details to come more
excited to bring allison on board we
think it's awesome we're not only
excited to have our talent here but
we're excited to provide a place for
people to land when they stand up for
the right things at their wok
corporations and we need your help to do
that so please head on over to
dailywire.com subscribe use code do not
comply for 25 percent off we do this
with gina carano another thousand
williams we'd love to continue doing
this it helps us build because if
hollywood is just going to expel
talented people we are happy to take
them in but beyond that we also want to
provide an alternative we want to make
sure that people know that hollywood
can't just cancel people without us
uncanceling them that is our goal here
we need your help to do that as members
so please head on over to dailywear.com
subscribe and use code do not comply for
25 off and help us fight these jerks
we'll get to all the news in just one
moment first let me remind you that
you're spending way too much money on
your cell phone coverage the simple fact
is you think that you need verizon 18 t
or t-mobile because they have all of the
cell phone towers right well what if you
could get the exact same coverage as one
of the big guys except you'd be spending
a fraction of the money because here's
the thing all those big companies are
spending a tremendous amount of money on
marketing and overhead and the stores
that you never go to instead head on
over to puretalk usa puretalk doesn't
charge you for any of that garbage
instead they give you killer 5g coverage
on the same 5g network is one of the big
guys for about half the cost the average
family is saving over 800 a year so what
exactly is your excuse i made this
switch you can too keep your number keep
your phone or get huge discounts on the
latest iphones and androids get
unlimited talk text and six gigs of data
for just 30 bucks a month and listen if
you still want unlimited data you can
get it and still save a fortune go to
puretalk.com shop for the plan that's
right for you if a 30-day risk-free
guarantees you literally have nothing to
lose go to puretalk.com enter promo code
shapiro you will say 50 off your very
first month of coverage that is
puretalk.com promo code shapiro puretalk
is simply smarter wireless alrighty so
over the weekend the glen youngkin terry
mcauliffe race continued to be hot in
virginia that thing is basically neck
and neck you always have to give the
edge to the person who is in line with
the state registration numbers the state
registration numbers in virginia tilt
toward blue which means that if you're a
betting man you probably still have to
bet on mcauliffe despite the fact that
junkin is now running very very close
but that's kind of the whole point is
this was never supposed to be close in
the first place it has gotten so close
but now terry mcauliffe has been forced
to call in the reinforcements in the
form of barack obama who arrived in
virginia
to do what he does best sneer an
enormous number of americans it because
barack obama is both such a good
communicator and because he is such a
beloved media figure
people seem to ignore the fact that
barack obama is a giant elitist jerk
barack obama spends an enormous amount
of his time in politics just sneering at
other human beings just sneering at half
the american people and telling them
that all of their concerns are are
really just a waste of time that they're
concerned the things that they worry
about on a day-in day-out basis those
are not the highfalutin things that
barack obama in his ginormous mind
worries about he used to do this all the
time as president he would say well why
do we have to break a false choice it's
a false choice between x and y when the
real answer is listen to me and do
whatever i want and this is kind of his
schtick well he never went away from
that cause it worked for him
politicians find what works for them and
then they just keep doing it so barack
obama was campaigning for terry
mcauliffe and he did this again right
the idea is that if you're concerned
about any of the issues in virginia
surrounding critical race theory or
bathrooms in education or the loudoun
county school board covering up people
being raped in the bathrooms
what if you're concerned about any of
that according barack obama it's because
you're kind of crazy and it's a figment
of your imagination and you're wasting
your time right any issue that you
deeply care about is a waste of time
according to barack obama because it's
fake outrage nobody's really outraged
nobody's truly outraged that the loundy
the loudoun county public schools
decided to
tell the entire public that nobody had
been raped in a bathroom and then it
turns out that a girl had been allegedly
raped in a bathroom
nobody is truly outraged over critical
race theory which indeed is being taught
in a huge number of american public
schools
nobody is super worried about that
they're it's all fake it's all pretend
in reality
everybody that doesn't like barack obama
is pretending not to like barack obama
deep down they actually like barack
obama and terry mcauliffe and the
democratic party agenda it's all fake so
here is barack obama pretending that
everyone who is not on his side of the
aisle is engaged in what he called fake
outrage
we don't have time
to be
wasting on these phony trumped-up
culture wars
this fake outrage
that right-wing media's pedals to juice
their ratings and the fact that he's
willing to go along with it instead of
talking about serious problems that
actually affect serious people
that's a shame
that's not what this election is about
phony trumped-up culture wars right so
according to the left anything you're
worried about is phony trump's culture
wars now you'll notice that there is a
trend here
the left does something very radical and
then the right response to the thing
that has been done that is radical and
then the left says you're engaged in a
phony trumped up culture war
so if they decide for example just on a
very light kind of minor level
culturally speaking that superman is no
longer going to say truth justice in the
american way is going to say truth
justice in a better tomorrow and you
notice this and you say oh that's weird
and that seems to reflect a sort of
underlying anti-americanism that's a
phony trump trump culture war why are
you signing lap
when it comes to critical race theory if
it turns out that your children are
being told that they bear a certain
level of historical guilt because of the
color of their skin
and you notice this and you say you know
what i don't want my kids being taught
that stuff or let's say that in your
kid's school library there is lgbtq plus
radical propaganda for small children in
the library and you say i don't really
want that at the school because you
noticed it at the school that's a phony
trumped up cultural war why are you
paying attention to that stop it
okay because the idea from the left is
that unity can only be achieved if you
just don't notice what they are doing if
you just ignore what they're doing then
we can all be unified because here's the
thing the people who have pushed the
culture were in this country are the
people on the left when you disturb the
status quo and when you push in radical
directions culturally and then other
people notice that you're pushing in a
radical direction culturally it is not
they who are being divisive by noticing
it is you who are being divisive by
pushing the policy
you see this all over american life
right now
now you see it with regard to mask
policy you'll have people who say kids
have to mask up forever and then if you
notice this and you get mad they're like
it's a phony trumped up culture war why
are you so upset well maybe it's because
you're the one who's mandating that i
put a a cloth mask on my five-year-old
maybe it's that if you change the status
quo and people notice you changing the
status quo and people are angry
overwhelmingly are you changing the
status quo the problem is not them maybe
the problem is you
the reason i bring this up is because
this is the entire biden administration
in a nutshell they're pushing extremely
radical policy and then when you note
that they are pushing extremely radical
policy then they say it's a phony
trumped-up culture war
so to take a perfect example right now
we have a supply chain crisis in the
united states
and it's leading to higher prices we
have a blowout spending crisis that we
have created over the course of the last
two years
partially
explanatory explainable because of the
coveted pandemic particularly some of
the financial activity last year but
this year not so much we've just been
blowing out the spending to for no
particular reason other than that joe
biden wants to fundamentally shift the
way we do economics in this country
okay so we have a major inflationary
crisis we have millions of people who
are not re-entering the workforce we
have a border crisis in which we have
record numbers of people who are
crossing the southern border illegally
we have a complete surrender on the
foreign policy front to the taliban in
afghanistan we have a very threatening
china on their eyes
those would be the kind of serious
issues that barack that serious people
talk about in the words of barack obama
right those are the serious issues that
serious people talk about so what would
you call an administration that is
deploying its useless vice president to
talk about the national gender strategy
would that be serious people talking
about serious topics and i imagine that
barack obama would consider this a
serious person talking about a serious
topic
because that's not a phony culture war
that's a thing that requires real change
according to the left when the left
declares a culture war they're not
declaring a culture war they're fighting
back against the pillars of the
institutional hierarchy that must be
torn to the ground so again while this
administration is experiencing crisis
after crisis that is affecting real
lives and the polls show it right now
americans care more than anything else
about issues like bread and butter
butter issues inflation job creation are
people going to get back to work are
there going to be products on the
shelves
am i going to have to compete in my
local community with vast swathes of
illegal immigrants who are coming in
without any sort of papers or am i going
to have to deploy more taxpayer dollars
in order to help those people
are we going to be able to fight off the
rising threat right these are real world
issues instead of doing that this
administration is declaring culture wars
so kamala harris who again was selected
solely on the basis of her race and
gender
okay literally
joe biden said this he said i am looking
for a person who is a black woman
okay which meant that it was not about
her qualifications as a politician per
se she'd run a horrible campaign to this
point and slandered him in the course of
the campaign
i'm old enough to remember because i'm
more than two years old
when i was defending joe biden against
kamala harris and then he picked us his
vp because he needed a black woman on
the ticket to fulfill all the
intersectional criteria again that's not
a culture war when he does that it's not
a culture world only when you notice
it's a culture war so vp kamala harris
who is so useless that she has to have
her own crisis management team
she put out a tweet over the weekend in
the middle of all of these crises here's
what it said quote
president biden and i released the first
ever national gender strategy this is
our vision for the future of our nation
one that is bold in strategy and one
that this moment calls for
so you might first be asking yourself
what in the hell is a national gender
strategy
hey really what does that even mean
like gender exists
that's that's like saying a national
human strategy
what are we talking about here well you
know what they're talking about what
they're talking about is the fundamental
principle of this foolish movement on
the left which is that every inequality
in american life can be struck up it can
be chalked up to structural inequalities
can be chalked up to the structural
evils of the american system and so in
the middle of an economic crisis
in the middle of all these other crises
they're focused like a laser in
on the fact that some women
choose not to work in the same
industries as some men now realistically
speaking there are more women in college
than men there are many many more women
with graduate degrees than men according
to studies women fresh into the
workforce with the same qualifications
as men are making the same amount or
more than men are in most major american
cities
okay but according to kamala harris
because again this is a we're going to
talk about a phony trump culture war the
notion that women are widely
relegated to second-class status in the
united states is a lie okay it is just a
stupid lie that is easily falsifiable
and kamala harris is put you want to
talk about a phony trumped up cult this
would be it
this is also part of what barack obama
did back in 2012 and he declared that
mitt romney had declared some sort of
war on women yes mitt romney the most
milk toast human being ever to be born
on this planet
so what exactly is their national gender
strategy
according to the white house president
biden and vice president harris believe
that advancing gender equity and
equality is fundamental to every
individual's economic security safety
health and ability to exercise their
most basic rights it is also essential
to economic growth and development
democracy and political stability and
the security of nations across the globe
ensuring that all people regardless of
gender have the opportunity to realize
their full potential is therefore both a
moral and strategic imperative
moral it's
a strategic imperative right to compete
with other nations we have to make sure
that there are gender neutral toy aisles
at the local at the local target
very very important stuff here
one of the things i enjoy the most about
the left is that they all talk like
kendall from succession i've ever
watched succession on hbo kendall is one
of the characters on succession and all
he does is he uses
sort of
murky pc lefty tech jargon so everything
is synergistic
that's how these people talk they just
string together words that make no sense
together in a paragraph of gobbledygook
and then declare themselves morally
superior
so says the white house no country in
the world has achieved gender equality
and we are at an inflection point well
maybe the reason that no country in the
world has achieved quote unquote gender
equal like what do you mean by gender
equality what they mean is every outcome
is the same maybe the reason not every
outcome is the same is because men and
women are different i know very
controversial stuff here but the
statistics show by the way is that
countries that have the widest social
safety nets like in northern europe the
ones that bernie sanders loves the most
also have the most gender discrepancy in
terms of for example stem jobs it turns
out that when women don't have to work
stem jobs they don't like working stem
jobs as much this should not be a
surprise men and women on a broad level
on average have different preferences
doesn't mean you can't have female stem
technicians doesn't mean you can't have
female engineers you can but they're
going to be far more rare in a free
choice society
than in a non-free choice society but so
long as that discrepancy exists we have
to fight back against reality the wokes
are at war with reality they're at war
in many cases with nature and then when
you notice this
they say that you have declared a phony
trumped-up culture war
it's it's true gaslighting
we'll get some more of this in just one
second first if you've got a small
business you know there's nothing more
valuable than your time so stop wasting
it on trips to the post office
stamps.com makes it easy to mail and
ship directly from your computer save
time and money with stamps.com send
letters and packages for less with
discounted rates from usps ups and more
here at dailywire we've used stamps.com
since 2017. no more wasting our time
since 1998 stamps.com has been an
indispensable tool for nearly one
million businesses including for us here
at daily wire stamps.com brings the
services of the us postal service and
ups shipping directly to your computer
whether you're an office sending
invoices or a side hustle etsy shop or a
full blown warehouse shipping out orders
stamps.com will make your life easier
all you need a computer and standard
printer no special supplies or equipment
within minutes you're up and running
you're printing official postage for any
letter any package anywhere you want to
send it and you get tremendous discounts
on postage and shipping from usps and
ups save time and money with stamps.com
no risk with my promo code shapiro you
got a special offer it includes a four
week trial plus free postage and digital
scale no long term commitments or
contracts just go to stamps.com click on
the microphone at the top of the home
page type in shapiro that is stamps.com
promo code shapirostamps.com never go to
the post office again okay so according
to the white house again very important
that we have a national gender plan
they say the covet 19 pandemic has
fueled a health crisis an economic
crisis and a caregiving crisis that have
magnified the challenges that women and
girls especially women and girls of
color have long faced now
i just quick note here
men die at a higher rate than women do
have covered 19. so if we're talking
about maybe that's is that because
society is structured to advantage women
or is it because men and women are
different
it has also exacerbated they say a
shadow pandemic of gender-based violence
in the united states and around the
world these overlapping crisis have
underscored that for far too long the
status quo has left too many behind i do
enjoy the biden administration preaching
to us about gender-based violence after
abandoning 19 million women to the
taliban there's a certain irony to the
taliban beheading women who refuse to
follow their dick tots with regard to
dress while the biden administration is
like well you know we really do care
deeply about gender parity this moment
says the white house demands that we
build back better error choirs that we
acknowledge and address long-standing
gender discrimination and the systemic
barriers to full participation that have
held back women and girls okay what
exactly are those long-standing barriers
to full participation
um they don't really name them they just
say that anywhere there is a discrepancy
then there must be a a discrimination
problem anywhere there's a disparity
there must be discrimination
they say this strategy adopts an
intersectional approach there we i mean
it's just it's all left-wing radical
buzzwords and if you notice
again if i notice this if i if i were a
politician and i campaigned on this
barack obama would then say why are you
paying attention to that why aren't you
paying attention to the fundamentals the
bread and butter
because you're not and we can see it
it's in plain sight it is terry
mcauliffe who declared in virginia that
parents should not be involved in
choosing the educations of their
children that was terry mcauliffe who
said that
not glenn youngkin
okay but if you notice it then you're
bad
this is why so many people are enraged
with media because they feel like the
media just act as a cover strategy for
these for these folks these people
preach radicalism and then the media
cover for them and then when you notice
it the media say why are you noticing
that
according to the white house the
strategy adopts an intersectional
approach that considers the barriers and
challenges faced by those who experience
intersecting and compounding forms of
discrimination and bias related to
gender race and other factors including
sexual orientation ethnicity religion
disability age and socioeconomic status
this includes addressing discrimination
and bias space right
black latino and indigenous native
american maple asian americans native
americans pacific islanders and other
people of color
so you have to say it all in one breath
or beetlejuice appears since it is all
one giant woke term
again the entire underlying notion here
is that if there is any discrepancy
between men and women it must be because
the system is unfair and you should give
full power to joe biden in this
administration in order to correct those
discrepancies
can and unless you think that this is
only with regard to sexual discrepancies
kamala harris
your your gender warrior
she also makes clear that this is about
racial discrepancies any time there's a
discrepancy in american life
any time there's a disparity in american
life it must be discrimination and the
only way you'll be shocked to learn this
the only way
to rectify these imbalances
is to give these people more power to
completely take over the economic system
and redistribute as they see fit
but if you're not see now to me that
seems like a very basic root issue if
the entire case that you are making for
more power is that bad things happen in
life give us all the power and we will
fix all the bad things and by bad things
we mean differential consequences that
stem in many cases from differential
decision making
we understand that in a free market
capitalist system your decisions are
generally rewarded or punished based on
the utility of your action
if you make a bad decision you tend to
be punished in the real world reality
does this
but the entire basis of democratic party
policy now is that if somebody does
something smart and is rewarded and then
if somebody does something dumb and is
not rewarded this is in and of itself
bad
this is why they like to chalk
everything up to luck right this is the
language they use with regard to wealth
is always the more fortunate and the
less fortunate well i'm sorry but jeff
bezos isn't just quote unquote more
fortunate if you look at his life story
and you looked at his childhood you'd
say that guy is not super fortunate okay
but he made many many good decisions the
complete disconnecting and the overt
disconnecting between positive action
and positive results is a goal of many
people in politics they want to insulate
you from your own decision making and
that's comfortable for a lot of people
because it means that if you fail that's
not your failure that's society's
failure
so here is kamala harris suggesting
that every injustice is linked with
economic injustice so she says racial
injustice is linked with economic
injustice the notion of course being
that if there is disparity in the wealth
holdings between black and white in the
united states that is entirely due to
current day discrimination
which is entirely false if you want to
say that that is due in in certain
measure
that we have not yet really disclosed
that that is doing certain measure to
historic injustices that's inarguable
that's not the argument that kamala
harris and joe biden are making the
argument they're making is that any
disparity between black and white wealth
holdings today is because the system
today today like right now is racist and
we have to completely redo the economic
system to give them more power
to presumably redistribute along the
lines of race here's kamal harris
pushing this racial injustice today
is inextricably linked
to economic injustice
to the impact
of the climate crisis
of covet 19
and to the threats
to our democracy
and i believe then
knowing and seeing that
the path forward is clear
we must put people to work in good union
jobs
oh weird so like you could completely
disregard everything she said in the
first part of that statement and just
finished with the last part of the
statement you should therefore do this
thing i want you to do so she just
throws all these buzzwords out there
climate justice and the environment and
covet 19 and the fact that there aren't
enough women around the world who can
access tampons and the fact that that
there are wild injustices in the way
that small children are being treated in
bangladesh right like she's just
throwing everything against the wall and
then at the very end she's like oh yeah
and because the world is filled with
injustices and bad things therefore do
this thing i want you to do
okay now
here this is why when barack obama says
things like this is fake outrage it's
not fake outrage because your entire
strategy is tied up in a generalized
viewpoint that delivers and and must
deliver culture war
the cultural warrior here the cultural
warriors here are on the left and it is
part and parcel of a of a an ideological
agenda to rejigger all of humanity
understand there's a fundamental debate
here about the nature of human beings
so on the right you have people who
believe that there is such thing as a
fundamental human nature that people are
both capable of sin and people are
capable of great things
and that you have a free ability
as much as humanly possible to make
choices within that context that drive
you towards success or toward failure
you as a human being are given the
ability to reason you have a prefrontal
cortex and this allows you to make
decisions and be held responsible by
reality for those decisions and reality
tends to punish bad decisions and then
you have people who believe it's a very
left-wing viewpoint that human nature is
entirely malleable that reality counts
for nothing and that if you shift the
systems in which we live
then that will transform humanity into
something better that is the root
messianic vision of the left
it's something that marx talks about he
really never talks about human nature
what he does talk about is human beings
as sort of widgets who are shaped by the
environment in which they live now
there's a lot of self-contradiction
there because the idea is also that
people at the top levels get to reshape
the systems in which we live which means
that they are free of the burdens of
being widgets
but if you but if you put that aside the
basic idea here is give kamala harris
and company enough power and they will
reshape all of these systems and thus
usher in a new era for humanity in which
all of the bad things will disappear all
of them economic justice will happen and
then everything that follows will just
be wonderful there will be equity and
equality and every other word beginning
with e including elephantitis all of
those things will just happen all at
once and this is being preached by this
administration through and through this
is not an irrelevant side battle this is
the battle okay and all these little
issues that we argue about on a
day-by-day basis whether it is crt or
whether it is transgender bathrooms all
these little issues are merely little
blips on the surface of the underlying
debate which is very vast and very deep
and really matters a lot
okay so this administration continues to
foster the notion that any inequality in
american life is due to inequity is due
to unjustness america garland remember
this guy was supposed to be milk toast
he's supposed to be bland merrick
garland when he was picked as a.g this
guy was a representative of the law now
he just targets parents who are
complaining about critical race there
merrick garland gave a speech the other
day in which he talked about the racial
inequalities in american life in terms
of for example the wealth gap
redlining contributed to large ratio to
the large racial wealth gap that exists
in this country
the practice made it extremely difficult
for people of color to accumulate wealth
through the purchase
refinancing or repair of their homes
that discrepancy in wealth is clearly
reflected in current home ownership
rates
today a white family is 30 percent more
likely to haul or own a home than a
black family
this present day gap in home ownership
rates is larger than it was in 1960.
okay perhaps the reason that the black
homeownership rate is larger than it was
in 1960 is not due to additional racism
in the system maybe that is due to a
giant welfare state that incentivizes
bad behavior
maybe it's that
in fact so glenn lowry who's an
economist over at brown university he
does an excellent podcast and he has
conversations with other economists and
he speaks very often with them about
race and inequality and all of this so
he writes this week
in my recent discussion with historian
david kaiser he noted the vast majority
of racial wealth disparities between
black and white americans occurs among
the top 10 of the income distribution
while black white disparity in the
bottom 50 are very very small okay the
way that you hear merrick garland
talking the idea is that all black
people are 30 percent less likely than
all white people to own houses that's
not right okay what is being suggested
here by the historian david kaiser is
that if you look at people in the bottom
half of the income distribution their
economic lives look very similar it is
only the very top end where you have a
wide discrepancy in terms of wealth
ownership
moreover says david kaiser between 1940
and 1980 black homeownership rates rose
slightly faster than white home
ownership rates those numbers tend to
deflate the narrative that redlining
excluded blacks from the economic boom
that followed the new deal and world war
ii it also happens to be the fact that
while redlining was undoubtedly had was
racist and had a racial component while
that is true by the late 1960s by the by
the 1970s that was illegal under federal
law
so we've had two generations of that
being illegal under federal law
not only that it turns out the vast
majority of people who are living in red
line districts as pointed out by john
mcquarter in the new york times again
these these folks are not
wild conservatives
john mccorter is a is a typical
down the line democrat when it comes to
his voting habits
when it comes to redline districts some
85 percent of people who are living in
red line districts were white
which suggests that a lot of those red
line districts had a lot to do with the
income of those districts and maybe
something to do with raise but it wasn't
entirely due to raise
according to that historian david kaiser
and point this stuff out because again
the idea is that any inequality that
exists today
is because the system today is bad even
by the way if you believe that it would
be only entirely because of red lighting
that would not explain what you're
supposed to do today are you supposed to
discriminate against people today in
favor of discrimination in the past i
mean that's about max kennedy's solution
okay according to david kaiser
the black population was not left out of
the economic gains generated by the new
deal the second world war and the
immediate postwar period it gained more
rapidly during that period than it has
since that tells me that progress
depends a lot more on the general
economic climate and the government's
policy toward lower income americans
than it does on the extent of racism
since legal racism was much worse in the
earlier period than since 1980.
according to samuel cronin writing for
colette the wealth gap perfectly
illustrates a problem with using
statistical disparities to diagnose and
address social issues an analysis by the
people's policy project which is a
left-leaning institute reflects just one
of the problems with what coleman hughes
has called the disparity fallacy by
uncovering an element of the racial
wealth gap that's gone unremarked upon
in most mainstream discourse
the gap between the wealthiest 10 of the
white population and the wealthiest 10
of the black population accounts for
77.5 of the total wealth gap in other
words when you look at the the average
wealth gap that is a misleading stat
because basically what you're saying is
the wealthiest white americans are a lot
wealthier than the wealthiest black
americans but when you get below the
wealthiest 10
the disparities start to disappear
although the racial wealth gap exists to
some degree across class lines if we
were to eliminate the disparity between
the bottom at 50 percent of blacks and
whites in terms of wealth a full 97
percent of the total gap would remain
only three percent of the racial wealth
gap is explained by the disparity
between the poorer half of each
population which is the part that we're
focused on when you talk about for
example merrick garland saying it's much
easier for a white person to get a house
than for a black person to get a house
and nobody is worried about whether jeff
bezos has a bigger house than kanye
that is not the wealth gap that we are
concerned about you're concerned
theoretically about the wealth gap for
the bottom 50 percent which
statistically is much much more of a
minor issue but you have to pretend that
it's a much bigger issue in order to
call for world-beating change
and this is true across this
administration
again across this administration
everything inevitably is about the the
notion that
inequality and inequity are exactly the
same thing
and this is being in and your kids are
being indoctrinated with this so unc
chapel hill is now giving out mandatory
woke training
according to hot air
university of north carolina at chapel
hill recently held a mandatory training
session for all greek organizations on
campus carolina review the campus
conservative newspaper got leaked audio
from the training and also spoke to
people who attended
apparently the person who was speaking
here
whose name is parl started a
presentation with an indigenous land
recognition after which hundreds of
greek attendees were advised they should
make a habit of repeating the political
catechism in their daily lives and
taught how to do so after establishing
her lecture was on stolen land powell
asked students their feelings about the
system were they warm toward it
apathetic or ready to dismantle it
at this point parle started talking
about the role of identity and the
social constructs which defined them a
subject which introduced the
presentation and remained a focal point
throughout
she emphasized that identity is a
primary factor in life experience
explaining that identity guides the way
you navigate the world and students were
instructed to write their intersectional
identities like sex and race and sexual
orientation and body size on a piece of
paper and here's what it sounded
it like that every grocery store
literally almost across the nation was
built from the average type person
in this really experienced service
and all humanity would experience
oppression in some way they were
okay i'm sorry this is insanity but this
again this goes back to the idea that
any disparity is some form of she
literally says in this presentation
okay this is not now because i'm
discussing a woke training session at
unc chapel hill this is what barack
obama would call a culture war that is
fake outrage okay except that it goes to
the heart of left-wing ideology right
now this lady is speaking to it she
literally says that if you have to reach
for the top shelf
at a grocery store because you can't
reach it you have to have somebody else
to help you have suffered oppression
right every single person in the room
she says has benefited from oppression
and suffered from oppression because the
world was built for the average
okay so i just have a question who else
would it be built for what is her
proposed solution
should we have
presumably the the
height of the shelves because it's built
for the average person should it be
built for the lowest common denominator
presumably that means that all shelves
at the grocery store should only be
about three foot five high
and you'd have to lease twice the space
at the grocery store in order to fit
everything you'd have to have a much
much bigger store in order to be able to
even lay out the goods so so nobody has
to take the horrifying step of asking a
a person who works at the store or a
person walking down the aisle to reach
something for them by the way i'll just
note here that actually
it creates a sort of communal comedy the
fact that people have to ask each other
for help sometimes that's not the end of
the world
i was at target the other day and
there's a lady there and she'd lost her
glasses and she couldn't read the label
on the bottom of a lamp that she wanted
to buy so she asked me for help
and i read it for her and we kind of
smiled at each other we moved on that
wasn't a bad thing because she wasn't
oppressed
but but the idea here again is that all
structures of oppression are bad and how
are you going to dismantle them
okay that's not a mild cultural issue
it has ramifications for everything
across all areas of american life and
this is how you end up with videos from
buzzfeed about how you have six separate
genders and if society doesn't take into
account six separate genders that's
because society is oppressive
when you get to the point where
everybody's subjective identity is
supposed to be accepted celebrated and
built for by the society
then you can't have a society at all
because literally this stuff is
subjective it changes on a moment's
notice you have no objective way of
verifying any of that you can't
construct a society the point is the
chaos the point is the confusion it is
the same as the gobbledygook that is
being spewed by this administration in
justification of radical economic policy
it is all part of the same deal
which is that there will be no objective
reality to which we all answer that will
just disappear into the ether and any
objective reality is a form of
oppression it is a form of oppression if
somebody doesn't accept that you call
yourself a unicorn
it is a form of oppression if you have
to reach for the top shelf and it is a
form of oppression if there is one group
of people in the united states that is
poorer than another group of people in
the united states and you don't even
have to look at whether there is a
disparity between how people in one
group
act in the aggregate not individually in
the aggregate you don't have to look at
the historic circumstances and you don't
have to look at whether the corrective
to that might be more of a problem than
the actual problem itself
so here's how
in terms of gender it manifests is just
complete gobbledygook sheer insanity
here we go from this insane buzzfeed
video
what is your gender i identify female i
am
male for me there's a little bit of a
difference um between gender and gender
expression i would say
is it feminine i can't say the word
my gender is feminine i was born
anatomically scientifically doctors were
like that's a girl but as i grew up i
was like that doesn't really work for me
i feel like i'm a more masculine person
like like a cis smells would
like i know i think i would classify as
that as well but i'm just like
i'm so uneducated yeah
i i guess i never questioned it either
to be honest with you so
it's a matter of education right it's a
matter of indoctrination i'm just
uneducated none of these people know
what they're talking about because it's
complete nonsense but the idea is that
if all of reality is not reconstructed
to fit their particular identity then
society itself is oppressive
there is no more you cannot have a
society this way
what you can have is sure
sheer tyranny you can have people who
are empowered to fix every problem in
american life and protect you from the
vicissitudes of an actual real world
that is not that is going to bite back
against you see this is the stupidity of
all this we can play this naval gazing
game where we pretend that all of these
systems of reality no longer apply
because we become so wealthy and so fat
maybe we can do that but eventually
reality will win because reality is
still out there reality is still reality
if we decide that just as a society
we're going to embrace stupidity
societies that don't embrace stupidity
are going to benefit and flourish in the
reality that exists
and those ones will overtake us it is
that simple people who deny reality lose
societies that deny reality lose
i root for reality because i think that
reality always wins anyway it's like
rooting for the yankees eventually
they're always going to win
okay we'll get to the economic plans of
this administration which again are tied
in very heavily to this underlying
ideological remolding and reshaping of
humanity in just one second first let's
talk about the fact that your gas prices
right now are just out of control out of
control somebody showed me the gas price
in california yesterday some people are
paying like seven bucks a gallon up to
eight bucks a gallon you know you could
use some money back on that this is why
you need to get an incredible app that
everyone who buys gas needs to know
about get upside my listeners are making
up to 25 cents for every gallon of gas
every time they fill up just download
the free get upside app in the app store
or google play right now
use promo code shapiro get a bonus 25
cents per gallon on your first fill up
that is up to 50 cents cash back don't
pay full price to the pump anymore get
cash back using get upside today just
download that app for free use promo
code shapiro to get up to 50 cents a
gallon cashback on that very first tank
of gas
some people who drive a lot are making
as much as 2 or 300 bucks a month in
cash back there is no catch the cash
back gets added directly to your account
you can cash out anytime to your bank
account paypal or an e-gift card for
amazon and other brands just download
the free get upside app use promo code
shapiro to get up to 50 cents a gallon
cashback on your very first tank of gas
that is code shapiro go check out that
get upside app right now use promo code
shapiro get up to 50 cents per gallon
cash back
on your first tank of gas and up to 25
cents for every gallon of gas thereafter
alrighty folks disney did it again now
we're not talking about your average
sort of propagandistic film as you may
have heard last week the entertainment
goliath fired allison williams
essentially they forced her to resign
because she wasn't going to vaccinate
and they have a vaccine mandate over
there she announced her resignation her
decision did not go unnoticed
specifically by us and she said that
she'd already had covet she wanted to
get pregnant she was concerned about the
vaccine she didn't want to get the facts
and so she left because she still
believes in freedom to choose whether
you're going to inject herself with a
vaccine for it to prevent a disease that
has a very low chance of killing you we
at daily wire are very much against
these vaccine mandates right we said
that from the very beginning and so we
went out of our way to sign allison
williams to lead a very special sports
series exclusively for our members more
details to come we're excited to do this
right our goal here is to uncancel those
who are canceled to provide a place for
people to land when they don't wish to
bow to the leftist headmasters at their
institutions here at the daily where the
leftist elites are not going to dictate
our content you do and we need your help
right for us to continue doing this sort
of stuff we do need your help if you
want premium entertainment and sports
content without the woke become a member
at dailywire.com subscribe use code do
not comply at checkout for 25 off we're
building a movement against the leftist
hollywood machine and joe biden's
unconstitutional mandate but we need
your help so go to dailywire.com
subscribe today code do not comply for
25 off and join the fight
also if you want to wake up to the facts
rather than the legacy media's neatly
spun lies i highly recommend our newest
podcast morning wire not only has it
been topping those apple and spotify
charts since its release it is the only
daily podcast that values your time and
the truth and while we are working
overtime to bring you the news you need
to know we need your help to keep the
facts trending toward number one so
subscribe start listening right now to
morningwire on apple spotify or wherever
you listen to podcasts leave a five star
review if you like what you hear you're
listening to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
all righty so what is all of this
wokeness and radicalism and service to
control it's in service to more economic
control now what's amazing about the
economic control that's currently being
leveraged by the biden administration is
that it is resulting in bad things like
right away
if you go back and listen to my podcast
at the beginning of the year before
biden took office i said that biden was
going to take office and my prediction
was he was going to have a solid two
years of economic growth like really
really good economic growth because all
he had to do was sit there and be a tree
stump
and he was actually qualified for that
right he's barely alive and he maybe
performs basic photosynthesis functions
at this point but that's pretty much it
so all he had to do was sit there and
drink and sure through a straw and watch
matlock for two years and the economy
was going to grow because we're going to
come out of the pandemic everybody was
going to go back to work and that was
gonna be that instead he decided no no
we need to blow out the spending we need
to freak everybody out about covid for
no apparent reason at this point we're
just gonna freak everybody out
and the predictable results have been
bad and so now you have the amazing
spectacle of this administration
actively talking down expectations okay
actively telling you you need to expect
less expect less by the way there's
always a great dating strategy on a
first date you should always tell the
person you're dating to expect less now
politics is a constant date right
because no one ever really gets married
in politics at the very end you have to
decide you know whether you're going to
vote for somebody or not but then they
have to run for re-election okay so you
know what is a bad date strategy you go
on the first date and you're like you
know what
i'm just going to tell you
i may look good right now but you really
got to have set your expectations low
like really lower those expectations
that would be a good indicator that you
need to get up and run from the room but
that's exactly what this administration
is now doing because their policies suck
here is gensake
saying from the perch at the white house
we need to expect less from joe biden on
gas prices it turns out this is their
line across pretty much everything now
i think the president as we as i said
earlier was quite candid last night as
the american people should express from
him
expect from him and from any president
um and there are limitations to what any
president can do as it relates to gas
prices here's what we have been doing as
we've said for some time we're engaging
broadly with opec on our concerns at a
range of levels um and that is something
we will continue to do
lower your expectations vox has an
entire piece today
titled
it's time for americans to buy less
stuff
and this is going to be good for you
according to terry nguyen who's writing
for a box it's gonna be good for you
it'll make your life better quote the
alternative isn't a moral neutral must
we continue to drown in our unlimited
and unfettered need for more stuff or
could we start buying less
we should just stop by this would be
good for you you understand you always
thought that having the ability to buy
what you want and having it delivered on
time was a good thing wrong you are
it turns out we should reframe the
conversation around sustainable living
turns out you should be happy with less
your life is better with less your life
getting materially worse is better for
you spiritually
according to daniel fisher assistant
professor at the school of
sustainability at arizona state
university people often assume they're
adopting a lower quality of life by
owning and buying less
we need to flip this narrative around he
says and emphasize how sustainability
allows you to have a better quality of
life it's not about renunciation but
choice
in a consumer society he says our base
impulse is to desire material goods that
satisfy our needs people have
fundamental needs food shelter safety
and more advanced self-actualized wants
most people aren't aware of how to
discern those motivations they buy
because they feel like it
fisher believes people can be trained to
break out of this cycle of consumption
okay so
understand they're not making this as
like a spiritual religious claim that we
should cling to the spiritual and
eternal right this is not their claim
their claim is instead
that you should be happy now that you
can't buy like actually the bite
administration is doing you a favor by
making you not be able to buy stuff for
christmas that's actually very exciting
stuff
it's it's really it's great it's great
so what exactly are the democrats now
doing with regard to policy they're
trying to blow out the spending and make
it worse
if you want inflation to get worse what
you do is put more money in people's
pockets without a consummate rise in the
supply of goods
as milton friedman famously explained
inflation is anywhere and everywhere a
monetary phenomenon
putting more money in people's pockets
when there are not enough goods to go
around creates inflation
so janet yellen
who is now the treasury secretary and
again i'm not upset that jenny ellen's
the treasury secretary i had i'm upset
she was ever the head of the fed it just
demonstrates how quote unquote
nonpartisan the fed is that a person can
shift directly from being federal
reserve chair to being treasury
secretary under the succeeding
administration without even a gap in
policy making so janet yellen was asked
by jake tapper why joe biden's throw
money at everybody policies won't super
heat inflation uh suffice it to say she
doesn't do great with us
if the american economy is already
overheating is spending even more money
potentially pouring gas on the inflation
fire well the additional spending in the
infrastructure package and in the
buildback better package
both of those are spending over 10 years
not in a single year
the rescue package
did involve substantial spending this
year and
let's remember that
a benefit of that package is that
unemployment is declined to four point
eight percent
i think she's lying to you the idea is
that without the ridiculous spending
package passed on purely partisan lines
earlier this year unemployment wouldn't
have declined um no i'm pretty sure
unemployment would have declined given
the fact that people had gotten the
vaccine and were going back to work you
know how i know that because
unemployment never even spiked in many
red states where people sort of treated
covid more casually so there's that so
jenny ellen is just lying to you now
right that if they blow out the spending
it's not going to create more inflation
and so some people are rightly asking
okay so you have a few problems one you
want to spend a lot of money you want to
blow out the debt you you also
would would like to restructure how work
is done and you're causing people to
drop out of the workforce so a lot of
problems so the democrats solution is
yet again something else that they have
pursued it's amazing how every
democratic problem has a solution that
drives you further along this path
everything is more cowbell right it's
all snl will ferrell more cowbell you
got a problem with inflation throw more
money at it the problem with the with
the monetary inflation is is getting
worse well we could throw more money at
it
and and then what if we don't have
enough money well what we could do is we
could take other people's money which is
what we wanted to do in the first place
okay it's not a bug of the system it's a
feature so now this administration is
claiming that they want to redo how
taxes are done
okay particularly for people who are
very wealthy so just understand anytime
people on the left say that a tax policy
is going to begin with the wealthy it
never ends with the wealthy remember the
original income tax proposed by woodrow
wilson was something like eight percent
on people in the top one percent
and now it's a huge percentage on
everybody so it's pretend nonsense where
you institute a tax and it just applies
to these five people and it's going to
stay that way forever it never stays
that way because as soon as the
government gets its foot in the door it
just wedges its shoulder and soon enough
it's in your house eating all the eggs
out of your fridge okay so here is nancy
pelosi promoting a wealth tax now it is
not clear at all whether this is
constitutional like a tax on actual
unrealized gain federally speaking
very questionable whether this is
constitutional given the fact we had to
pass an amendment to even allow the
income tax but here's nancy pelosi now
promoting the idea of a wealth tax
we probably will have a wealth tax yeah
but again it's only 10 of what we need
we and we the other things are more like
800 billion dollars versus 200 billion
dollars but we can use them another time
if they don't go away as a source of
revenue to pay for
how we go forward and we want to pay for
we said you probably will have a wealth
tax well that is it it will see we
haven't seen the bill yet right and you
said also that it's being written right
now you're going to and you're going to
send it to the
this is a senate proposal okay and they
supposedly are writing it today tomorrow
they would introduce it and then tax the
joint tax committee as the one that says
this is how much you get from that
okay janet yellen also wants a wealth
tax now here's the thing they all
understand that the predictable effect
of taxing unrealized capital gains is
that people are going to invest less
everybody knows this here's jenny ellen
trying to push it anyway i think what's
under consideration is a proposal that
senator wadden and the senate finance
committee have been looking at
that would
impose
tax on unrealized capital gains
on liquid assets held by extremely
wealthy individuals billionaires
i wouldn't call that a wealth tax but
it would help get at
capital gains which
are an extraordinarily large part of the
incomes of the wealthiest individuals
unrealized capital gains are not a part
if you don't realize a capital gain
you're not receiving that as income if i
don't sell stock i didn't receive the
upside of the stock unless i also get to
write off unrealized losses as tax
losses
but you don't it only works in one
direction
so this is an insane proposal it is a
crazy proposal so the democrats are now
proposing that for the people who are
the wealthiest in our society as
adjudicated by some sort of valuation of
their stockport portfolio
publicly traded maybe not publicly
traded we really have no idea we are now
going to force them to pay taxes on
unrealized gains on their stocks so you
own stock probably right over 50 percent
of americans do
every year you get your 401k report
let's say that your 401k went up 10 this
year it is conceptually speaking your
401k went up 10 you didn't sell any of
that stock did you realize any of that
gain
of course not that's unrealized gain
they're now proposing that for people
who are very wealthy that they'd be
taxed on unrealized game on stock they
did not sell
that's nuts that's nuts first of all
you'd have to figure out exactly how the
valuation is done because a huge number
of quote unquote billionaires
are people who are not in a publicly
traded stock and there are a lot of
billionaires across the united states
who own companies valuated over a
billion dollars but the stock is not
fluid it is not liquid it is not
fungible or you can't take that stock
and just sell it on the open market
okay or if you did sell it to sort of
the highest available bidder you might
undercut the price of the stock
according to the democrats quote a new
annual tax on billionaires on realized
capital gains is likely to be included
to help pay for the vast social policy
and climate package lawmakers hope to
finalize this week according to senior
democrats wall street journal reporting
the proposal under consideration from
senate finance committee chairman ron
wyden democrat of oregon would impose an
annual tax on unrealized capital gains
on liquid assets held by billionaires
and then you heard yelen say that you
wouldn't call that a wealth tax but it
is wealth tax
groups such as the national taxpayers
union have objected to the tax on
billionaires on realized capital gains
saying it would add more bureaucracy to
the tax system and impose it new burdens
on business investors
the tax is expected to affect people
with a billion dollars in assets or 100
million dollars in income for three
consecutive years
according to a person familiar with the
discussions
the idea for which biden recently
expressed support after excluding it
from his original campaign plans would
affect a narrower group of people than
the capital gains changes that have
already flopped among congressional
democrats
the emerging widen proposal would be
significantly more progressive it would
raise its money from the very very rich
likely fewer than a thousand taxpayers
instead of the merely rich
but house democrats are questioning
whether it makes sense to add a
relatively untested idea at this late
stage
the proposal under consideration would
focus on unrealized gains if it is and
it is expected to include a one-time tax
on gains to date
which means a tech company founder with
five billion dollars almost all of which
is unrealized gains would be taxed more
heavily than someone who just inherited
five billion dollars and has no
unrealized gains under the tax codes
i think it's likely i'm pushing hard
said elizabeth warren so just to
understand this
this means that if you founded a company
and your company is valuated at say two
billion dollars
they're not making clear by the way what
percentage they're gonna try and grab
every year but let's assume it's two
percent
so let's say that you are talking about
a two billion dollar valuation
and
you are supposed to pay two percent of
that each year of the two billion
dollars well two percent of two billion
dollars about 40 million dollars
okay so 40 million bucks
now let's say that that valuation
is not publicly traded stock let's say
that your two billion dollar company is
actually a company that does say 200
million dollars a year in business it's
got like a 10 times gross to do some
sort of valuation
and let us say that you've been paying
yourself a salary every year of maybe
five million dollars right you're paying
yourself a nice salary not like one of
these crazy
fifty million dollars out but about like
five million bucks a year because you
want your company to grow
so let's say you make five million bucks
a year
you're an and your company and you 100
your company your company is worth two
billion dollars now
if you sell the stock
then you've realized the gain and you
have to pay capital gains right that's
the current law but you didn't sell the
stock and the reason you didn't sell the
stock is because you want to stay in
control of your company also you realize
that if you sold the stock you would
lower the value of your company because
it would look like you wanted to get out
of your own company this actually
happened to mark zuckerberg a few years
ago he tried to sell a billion dollars
worth of stock in facebook and it tanked
the stock
because people thought that he was
trying to sell out of his own company
okay so
let's say that you've made five million
bucks a year let's say you built this
company over the course of the last
three years so you got 15 million
dollars in the bank now let's put aside
expenses 5 million bucks post tax you
have 15 million bucks in the bank
and now
they want to tax you let's say two
percent on the two billion dollar
capital gains you have not realized from
your company
your total your total liquid wealth in
the bank right now is 15 million bucks
plus stock that you can't really sell
and they're going to tax you at 40
million a year
that would be the simple math there
that's crazy
okay and again it's not going to stop
here once they start saying they're
going to tax unrealized gain you
understand that what this is going to do
is lead to a radical disincentive from
investment
instead you're going to see people find
places to put their money that is not
in this sort of situation
or they're going to find tax loopholes
they're going to find ways to convey
that that money to a trust for example
put their stock in and trust they don't
realize the game the trust realizes the
gain they get there are ways that people
can work around this sort of stuff so it
simply is not going to come up with the
same sort of numbers democrats think it
will they tried this in france people
found ways around it and started
incorporating their companies offshore
and moving offshore to avoid the wealth
tax
but for the for the democrats it's not
about anything except for the concept
they want the concept the reason that
elizabeth warren is fighting hard here
is not because she gives a damn about
deficits elizabeth warren is a proponent
of modern monetary theory which suggests
that deficits literally do not matter
she says this
she says openly debt does not matter
deficits do not matter nobody's ever
going to call it in we're still the best
economic bet on the block we can spend
as much money as we want so understand
that when she wants a wealth tax it is
not because she cares about filling in
the gap created by democrats budgeting
proposals she wants a wealth tax because
she wants to punish people for
investment
she wants a wealth tax because she would
love to see all investment taxed at a
higher rate
for redistributive purposes
that is the goal here
and then you have the media that is
pushing this stuff like incredibly hard
because they also would like to
restructure work
so just in the sort of modern moral
parlance of anti-capitalism in the media
the basic idea is that if you invest and
you create a company that's worth 2
billion you should be taxed on the
unrealized gains from that company but
if you're a teacher who dumps out of
school you're a hero
that is the way the media treat you
right now article in the washington post
today quote why so many teachers are
thinking of quitting
seven educators on how the pandemic
drove them to finally say enough is
enough now let's face it
teachers work particularly with public
sector unions and states like california
new york have a pretty sweet gig you can
almost never be fired
you have
you have three months of the year off
your salary and benefits are pretty good
okay but the the idea here
is the teachers are the great victims
now it may be that kids didn't get
educated for over a year here because
the teachers unions decided to basically
leave your kid a drift in public school
but it's the teachers who are the heroes
you have an entire left-wing
infrastructure that has decided if you
stay home from work you're a hero if you
build a company you're a
villain that's the essential point here
according to the washington post
teachers are dropping out at
extraordinary rates
whoever said those who can't do teach
obviously never experience the modern
educational system where teachers do
everything they're more than the people
who give math and science lessons they
might find themselves makeshift social
workers to troubled students surrogate
parents checking if children eat
security guards breaking up fights and
funders of the most basic of classroom
supplies from their own shallow pockets
now listen none of this is to deride
what teachers do
teachers do something quite important
but to pretend it's somehow heroic to
walk away from that
is insane and yet that's exactly what
this article is about teachers aren't
the only american workers taking part in
the so-called great resignation which
has seen many people in many industries
leave their jobs since the start of the
pandemic to find better pay and
satisfaction but the sheer numbers of
those contemplating an exit from the
classroom raises the question what's
happening and why
this washington post columnist says they
interviewed seven public school teachers
from around the country who have left
their jobs since march 2020 to
understand what they faced the
overarching sentiment quote
teaching was already too much and with
the increased stresses and demands
introduced by the pandemic they'd simply
had enough there's specific reasons for
resigning vary fear for their health and
that of their family
again first of all fear of your health
as a teacher is no greater than fear of
your it should be less than fear for
your health in any other endeavor in
which you have to be in a room with
humans kids have been transmitting this
at not the same rates as adults juggling
work and parenting from the literal
confines of their home
ex so then why are they quitting now
they're just going to be at home
presumably they'll have to find other
work you would think existing
frustrations with an education system
that never quite seemed to meet the
needs of students and staff some
struggled with remote learning others
didn't want to go back to the classroom
whatever their particular motivations
these former teachers were ready to move
on while many of them have been isolated
from their peers over the past year and
a half they are now united by the bold
act of walking away bold it's bold to
quit your job now
there's an agenda here and the agenda is
very clear
it is bold to walk away from your job it
is bold to rely on the taxpayers
that is bold that makes you better
and if you earn if you build companies
for whom hundreds of people work
thousands of people you're bad and we
should tax you and we should punish you
hey joe manchin apparently is now
warming up to the possibility of a
wealth tax to pay for this huge bill i
don't know if joe manchin just wants to
not win his senate seat in west virginia
or what
i don't know what joe manchin's
incentive structure here is to pass joe
biden's build back better plan by the
way if terry mcauliffe narrowly beats
glenn young by like a point or two or if
he loses and then joe manchin votes for
bill back better he's a political fool
because those states they're right next
door to each other
west virginia is the reddest state in
america
he will not have a senate seat if he
continues along these lines
manchin apparently is also thinking
about a corporate tax hike as well
according to the associated press
pivotal democratic senator joe manchin
appears to be on board with white house
proposals for new taxes on billionaires
and certain corporations to help pay for
president joe biden's scale back social
services and climate change package
they're not talking about a 1.75
trillion dollar package
that's within a range that could still
climb considerably higher apparently and
again remember that all the numbers
they're throwing around are just a lie
the numbers that they're throwing around
are false because they're using false
sunsets to pretend that these programs
are not going to be re-upped by
democrats
they're kicking in some programs years
down the road so they extend the 10-year
timetable to 15-20 years for some of the
programs
so apparently the the talk of 3.5
trillion is out the window but
apparently manchester is now considering
the possibility of this wealth tax and
and so is cinema
so
as much as we would hope for the
moderation of these particular
characters apparently that moderation is
not going to extend to not punishing
people for the great sin of creating a
business
okay meanwhile the other big story of
the day it is amazing i will say
america's love affair with dogs is
pretty astonishing
the way that it works in the united
states is that the taliban
are um the taliban kill a bunch of
american soldiers and behead a bunch of
people and take over an entire country
and americans are like mildly upset
about that or pretty upset about that
if we leave the dogs behind that's a
major issue okay in similar ways
so anthony fauci
lied about gain a function research and
he he defined gain of function research
as gain of function within an animal
right not gain of function meaning a bat
virus is now transmissible among humans
he says that's not gain of function then
there was a letter that just came out
from eco health alliance admitting that
the wuhan institute of virology was
making
bat viruses transmissible to humans by
testing it in mice
and so it turns out they were lying the
whole time so anthony fauci is out there
defending himself on the charge that he
lied in front of congress
i obviously totally disagree with
senator paul he's absolutely incorrect
neither i nor if dr francis collins the
director of the nih lied or misled about
what we've done the framework under
which we have guidance about the conduct
of research that we fund the funding at
the wuhan institute was to be able to
determine what is out there in the
environment in bat viruses in china okay
so he's still fibbing about this people
care a lot less about this than the fact
that he was experimenting on puppies now
isn't that a bond villain twist it turns
out that the guy who is funding
bat coronaviruses at the wuhan institute
of herology for gain of function
research
right and
this is not to suggest that fauci funded
the creation of coven 19 specifically
because the strains of virus that were
being researched under the nih grant
were different
but the guy who was funding the wuhan
institute of raleigh and money is
fungible the guy who's done a horrible
job throughout this pandemic while
trying to control all of our lives
it turns out that also he had greenlit
experimentation on puppies
little two on the nose the writing this
year is really on the nose i gotta say
this year so we're we're in season what
six now of trump
and uh and the writing has gotten
progressively worse like like most
series once you get past season three
the writing really starts to collapse
and the writing this season has just
been really on the nose according to
yahoo news dr fauci is facing a demand
from lawmakers on both sides of the isle
to divulge information regarding the
alleged use of an experimental drug on
puppies
democratic and republican lawmakers sent
a letter friday to joe biden and the
niaid requesting they share information
regarding the alleged infection of 44
beagle puppies with parasites in order
to test an experimental drug on them
according to the hill
the letter written by republican south
carolina representative nancy mason 23
other lawmakers says quote we write with
grave concerns about reports of costly
cruel and unnecessary taxpayer-funded
experiments on dogs commissioned by the
niaid
apparently
cordect cordectomies were performed on
six to eight-month-old dogs apparently
this is a devocalization it involves
splitting a dog's vocal cords in order
to prevent them from barking helling or
crying
it's opposed by the american veterinary
medical association and the american
animal hospital association
and apparently they're requesting
answers on how many drugs have been
performed on dogs since the beginning of
2018.
the the original report is a slightly
more graphic
apparently the parasites with which they
were infected
were really like very very unpleasant
apparently they're characterized as
cruel puppy experiments
according to the white coat waste they
said quote our investigators show that
fouchy's nih division shipped part of
375 800 grand to a lab in tunisia to
drug beagles and lock their heads in
mesh cages filled with hungry sand flies
so the insects could eat them alive
they also locked beagles alone in cages
in the desert overnight for nine
consecutive nights to use them as bait
to attract infectious sand flies
so basically they were reenacting the
nicolas cage scene from
wicker man
and they're like locking the beagle's
head in cages
which is just
horrifying with nih funding it will be
kind of amazing if what brings anthony
fauci down is that he was mean to dogs
not you know the four million dead
people
across the across the world thanks to
the wuhan institute of virology and also
not his complete failures during the
pandemic
but americans do love their dogs that is
for sure and meanwhile on the covenant
front
i i will admit that the the bond
villains are now coming out of the
woodwork so the new the new zealand
prime minister jacinda ardern right who
is getting all sorts of plaudits for
locking down her entire
country
which is basically
what is the population of new zealand
the new zealand population is
something like 5 million
and like a couple million hobbits and
some sheep so she locked down her entire
country was an island they didn't get a
big outbreak and she was celebrated for
this because as it turns out when you're
an island with five million people
a couple million hobbies of sheep it's a
lot easier to lock down and then she
didn't vaccinate anybody and then there
was an outbreak there anyway so now they
have vaccine passports over there that
they're really pushing and she just
admits straight up that she's trying to
create two classes of citizens
so you basically see it this is gonna be
like well it's almost like you probably
don't see like this the two different
classes of people if you're vaccinated
or if you're unvexited you have all
these rights if you are vaccinated that
is what it is so yep
yep yep and she's smiling well she says
yep if you're vaccinated you have all
these rights if you're unvaccinated you
don't have any rights man when they say
the quiet part out loud and they
celebrate it
just demonstrates that that if you have
populations that are basically willing
to concede to anything the so-called
experts tell them they will do anything
to you they will do anything to you
so long as you decide to give up liberty
in favor of a little temporary safety
things tend not to work out particularly
well especially when it turns out that
your experts are just lying to you
and which they are i mean it is amazing
every time the experts are asked about
why they got things wrong they just have
no good answer rachel lenski over at the
cdc was asked over the weekend about the
simple fact that everybody from anthony
fauci to richelle malenski to everybody
else were like we can't have stadiums
full of people stadiums full of people
are bad and we've had stadiums full of
people for months at this point no major
outbreaks at any of the stadiums
wellenski was asked about it and she
still won't back off the idea that it's
a really bad thing
what does it tell you that there have
not been spikes in most of these
communities when you have people crowded
into football or baseball stadiums
we would still encourage people who are
unvaccinated to wear a mask in those
situations but given that these games
are outdoors that tends to be a much
safer environment
well then maybe you should have said
that but you won't because it's about to
control it's not about fixing anything
as always it all as always is about the
tyranny and it is about the control
alrighty
we will be back here later today with an
additional hour of content in the
meantime go check out the michael
knowles show that's available right now
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pawel
wydowsky associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barbour
the show is edited by adam syavets audio
is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola cristina production
assistant jessica kranz the ben shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021
the nih admits that it funded gain of
function research in china contrary to
what dak defauci has been telling us the
cdc director proposes changing the
definition of fully vaccinated and that
exalted dr fauci tortures and kills a
bunch of puppies check it out on the
michael knowles show
[Music]